bonjour et combien votre lait 86 vous
savez que c'est on soude plus que ce que
la régie permet pour une troisième fois
en 17 ans l'épicerie a fait enquête sur
le prix du lait conventionnel le lait
sans valeur ajoutée pour une troisième
fois
on a malheureusement trouvé des fautifs
à montréal à québec et en région
principalement dans dépanneurs
indépendants du lait vendu de un à 47 de
plus le litre que les prises établi par
la régie des marchés agricoles et
alimentaires du québec
rien d'étonnant pour ce professeur en
distribution et politiques
agroalimentaires la délinquance au
niveau des prix minimums maximum ni par
la régie c'est quelque chose qui est pas
nouveau malheureusement les gens le
savent pas vous allez mandat n'importe
qui dans la rue quel est le prix minimum
et maximum pour un doublé de l'aide pour
ça je pas certain que les gens vont vous
répondre mais je suis pas certain qu'ils
vont pouvoir vous dire approximative de
2 litres
la régie reçoit quelques centaines de
plaintes par année pour l'association
des détaillants en alimentation du
québec
plusieurs raisons expliquent ces erreurs
de prix je voudrais évidemment pas tant
qu'il ya des commerçants non affiliés
des commerçants qui sont plus isolés ou
encore des opérateurs qui sont
allophones il y aurait plus de
difficultés à se retrouver dans la
réglementation mais je dirais que le
fournisseur également une responsabilité
lorsque vous vendez produit un
commerçant j'imagine que vous allez
vérifier de temps en temps
les contraintes de commercialisation
sont respectées la régie affiche sur son
site internet les prix minimum et
maximum en vigueur dans différentes
régions de la province
l'affichage de ces prix en magasin est
obligatoire mais très souvent absent
un autre règlement non respectés des
consommateurs peuvent déposer une
plainte s'ils sont témoins de ces
erreurs johane despins radio canada
montréal